well Eric Janson who's a sex researcher
at Kenzi has tried to come up with a
model to predict who will cheat and who
won't
and so the two important variables in
his sort of matrix of infidelity are
first your sensitivity to arousal and
there's a wide range of how easily
aroused people are and he does a test
where he asks you you know if if you
touch a stranger at a party or brush
against a stranger who you find
attractive do you become aroused if you
make eye contact with her do you or him
do you become aroused and these
questions are select out those people
who are much more sensitive to sexual
stimuli and I guess my sense is from his
numbers that it's probably around 40% of
the pool who answered yes a lot that it
kind of distributes itself now within
that group of people who are easily
sexual so these are your candidates in a
way for infidelity and for whom sex is
kind of their they're more in the water
you know they're just it's they're more
subject to sexual messages signals and
arousal and then but within that group
you have I guess it maybe splits half
and half of people who have a good brake
pedal these are all people who have a
strong gas pedal Luise a very sensitive
gas pedal but within that group some
people are more easily able to govern
that response and he seeks that group by
asking such questions as you know if you
are having sex with someone in a public
place and someone else comes along are
you does that cause you to become
apprehensive and and stop having sex and
you know for myself that question you
know
you know it's a nice fantasy I wouldn't
bother me if someone came you know long
I mean or the you know I wouldn't I mean
it wouldn't stop me and I think he has a
number of questions like that which are
determined to you know how much you
would stop yourself and how much of how
much risk would keep you from following
through on sexual behavior so the people
who that sort of twenty percent of his
model who have a strong sexual response
and don't sort of banish some of the
risks and fears about it those are the
people who are most prone to have
achieved in their marriages